hello everybody um
my name is sexy magallaris i am a
professor in the department of
biomedical engineering
at georgia tech and emory and
before that i was a professor
in the department of chemical
engineering at imperial college south
london
the work that i will be presenting to
you today is done by dr anakiroga
who is a phd and currently a postdoc in
my lab and it's on
model-driven design of cultural medium
culture meaning so
what i will be talking to you about
today is energy and
paraphrase the immortal words of bill
clinton it's the energy stupid
what i'll be talking to you
is atp
and fundamentally i will be talking to
you about
how we calculate the atp that is
provided to the cells
through the nutrients
and amino acids in the calcium medium
the atp that is generated by the cell
and then the atp that is required by the
cell
so that adp is at the center
of all activities including maintenance
proliferation
production and of course dealing with
stress so if we calculate
the atp that is provided to the cell
through the calcium medium the adp that
is generated by the cell
and the adp that is required by the cell
what we can do
is we can create
an energy a model an atp balance
which we can then utilize to optimize
our medium composition and as such
we will be able to come up with a medium
composition that
meets the requirements of the cell and
as you will see as i will describe
described later
significantly reduces the
concentration of of amino acids in the
calcium medium
but also will be able to generate a
feeding strategy
that will increase productivity
our approach involves
a model a mechanistic
complicated model but
a model that we have designed
specific steps on how to render it
highly predictive i'm not gonna go
through this
uh individual steps i'm going to
highlight only a few of them
but the model is at the center
of our platform as an
input to the model is data and the data
that we require
uh for the model include
cell composition so we're talking about
cell type
cell line and clone specific
cell composition information um
the data also include product
composition
so uh the specific uh in this particular
case
antibodies that the cell is producing
the growth kinetics so it is
clone specific data and this
data are saved into our model and the
model
captures the metabolism uh
the metabolic needs of the cell
the output from our model
is this precision media strategy
the precision media and the feeding
strategy and fundamentally uh
what this um uh platform shows
we have designed it to be an app or a
user interface for
let's say a batch or a fed batch or a
continuous
process the
for the specific cell type cell line
and clone and for the specific
antibody you will get a few things
number one the kinetics of
a carbon source and amino acid
utilization or production
the medium composition for the specific
again cell type cell line clone
and product system that you have
and the feeding strategy
so let's go through uh the example
that i'm going to use which is the dsms
0. this
cell line was provided by lonza um
it's producing an idd for
monoclonal and
we've uh validated
uh we produced experimental data using
both
uh flash calculus and also a body actor
especially when it came to the
feeding strategy so we use a one liter
benchtop bioreactor we use an
hplc to calculate amino acids and
concentrations and monoclonal antibody
concentration we use a bioprofiler to
calculate glucose lactate and ammonia
we use a flash flow cytometer to look at
live
and apoptotic cells and we use a lamina
luminometer to actually calculate
experimentally again is the atp that is
generated by the self so
we have the modeling platform let me uh
now
uh demonstrate to you or explain to you
how
the model interacts with the experiments
so that we can achieve both design of a
culture
a medium and also a design of an optimal
feeding strategy
so we have three phases and what i'm
trying to really tell you right now is
that
we can go from
zero to a medium design
and the feeding style is designed in a
cus
3 experiment so phase 1
involves the input of the data so we
need the cell composition data we need
the product composition data
and we performed the first batch
experiment
and out of this
phase one what we get and i'll explain
that
a little bit better in the next slide
what we get
are actually the data that we put
in the model including uh uh
the parameters estimating the parameters
for
the model phase two once we have
completed phase one
is model validation so in a separate set
of experiments
uh what we do is we validate the
model by a different as a set of
experiments
and what that allows us to do is
validate the model and
be able to come up with an initial
medium composition and feeding schedule
if at phase two the validation does not
pan out we have to go back to phase one
uh if it does stand out then we move to
phase three
and phase three is the optimal
medium composition uh and the optimal
fitting strategy
for a fat batch or a continuous process
so phase 3
is now model utilization
whereby we use the model to design our
optimal
system
every module to use the words of
george box is wrong some
models are useful so
that is true for our model
and how we render the model in our case
useful is um at
one step whereby we use a mathematical
applause approach
uh and technique called global
sensitivity analysis
which allows us to look at the
parameters of the model
and identify which model parameters
are really significant and affect the
model output so for example if we set
the model output to be
cell number or productivity or viability
or whatever you may
want there will be a set of parameters
that
influence the model output so using this
global sensitivity analysis technique
we vary all parameters
at the same time plus or minus 50
for the duration of the culture period
what
that allows to do is identify
uh the significant parameters we
actually rank them
uh uh from zero to one
zero being insignificant and one being
significant
we actually set an arbitrary a cutoff
point of
0.1 whereby anything 0.1 we consider
significant anything
less than 0.1 we consider insignificant
what you see from the table here uh
was that we identified 14 significant
parameters
out of approximately uh 40 so about
a third were significant and the next
thing you see is that
these parameters are not significant for
every period or every phase in the
culture
period and i will
mention a few parameters because they
will become important
uh later on when we use the mod
so right now we haven't done
any any experiments yet this is what
the model tells us and it identifies
a parameter linked with glutamate
aspartate and arginine for example
that are significant
and what you see interestingly let's
look at
arginine that is significant in the
first 72 hours and it becomes
insignificant later on
um or you look at glutamate that it
it becomes extremely significant
at after 96 hours
the importance of what i'm telling you i
will demonstrate later on
what this mathematical analysis allows
us to do is
design the experiment we are at phase
one whereby we can get experimental data
to accurately estimate this parameter
if we're talking about the monon
constant for glutamate
what we need to do is get experimental
data
after really 120
hours because that's when this parameter
becomes extremely important
uh maybe i should illustrate that better
with them or not constant for arginine
we would
uh get the data at the beginning of the
culture we won't
care later on because that parameter is
not significant
so once we have done this experiment we
have completely now
phase one we have a model that we are
going to validate
and what i'm going to discuss from now
on is module validation
what i'm showing you in this slide uh
are four graphs
viable cells monopole antibody
concentration early and
late apoptotic cells for
four different cell densities the
red cell density 1 times 10 to the 8
cells per liter
is the one recommended by lunch
and the reason why we did four different
cell densities is because
again models are notorious for being
valid
at a very limited range of operating
conditions what we wanted to do is
show how well the model performed under
a wide range of operating conditions
under wide range of inoculate inoculum
densities from 1 times 10 to the 8
to 4 times 10 to the 8th cells per liter
and
what you can actually see from these
graphs is that
the model captures uh very accurately
again
90 of the data within the 95 confidence
intervals
um for a wide range of operating
conditions
what else does the model capture well it
captures
metabolic shifts so it can predict
when in a batch culture
amino acids are going to be exhausted
and when
the metabolism of the cell change
so let's look at four examples i'm going
to focus
on glutamate top left and what you see
is approximately at
72 hours glutamate is exhausted
and the cells even though glucose is
still abundant
the cells swift a sifter metabolism
and they start consuming uh glutamate
sorry proline which is the third graph
in the top set of graphs
so proline is not really consumed uh
for the first 72 hours and once
glutamate is exhausted
we start seeing uh utilization of
proline
remember glutamate we have found
in our global sensitive analysis
the importance of glutamine
the second metabolic shift is linked to
aspartate
and again around 72 hours
we have exhaustion there about depending
on
inoculum density of aspartate
and that means that
the cell shifts its metabolism and
starts utilizing
phenylalanine what i've just said is
summarized in this slide
and the point that i want to make is
that again
we see metabolic shifts whereas glucose
is abundant
and once these
amino acids are exhausted this metabolic
sieve
is permanent it doesn't really matter if
you provide
again aspartate or glutamate by and
large
and it is a line specific
this metabolic shifts can become
permanent
our model predicts uh two more metabolic
shifts
iso using and leucine are about 96 hours
where you have exhaustion of isolucine
and then
once that happens you have the
utilization of alanine
and you have exhaustion of leucine and
you have the
utilization of lysine the importance
here is that isoleucine and leucine
are essential amino acids so what i'm
trying to tell you is that we have a
model
that dynamically can tell us what
is happening with all amino acids and
carbon sources as a function of
cell density as a function of
productivity
so the model predicts
the availability of nf the second thing
the model predicts
is the energy the atp produced by the
cells
so we have four graphs here um
these four graphs are for the different
inocula
inoculum densities and
what you see is the atp that is
generated
in millimoles per
cell per liter and again
for the different inoculum densities the
model
with high fidelity predicts
the adp produced per
cell dynamically for the different
phases
of the culture time so what we have so
far just to summarize we have a
predictive model
which is high fidelity model it's
dynamic
it operates under wide range of
experimental conditions
and it captures the metabolic shifts
of the cells
so we can have a model
that captures the energy available to
the cells
nutrient concentrations the energy
produced by the cells
atp and the third thing that it can
capture is the
energy required by the cells and again
this is
the cell type cell line clone
and a product specific
number but you can what you can see from
the top left graph
is that for this gs and a0 clone
for the particular antibody
the energetic requirement is
the magical number of five times ten to
the minus twelve
millimoles of atp per viable cell
whereby if you drop below that number
you have a zone in the top right graph
you have the onset of apoctosis so
what that means is that if your nutrient
composition your medium composition
does not deliver the sufficient energy
for the cells to produce the required
atp
you will have as early as 72 hours
even though you are at the exponential
phase at the middle of the exponential
phase
you will have the onset of apoptosis and
we can predict
the importance of this number is that
this is the constraint
that we use in the model so we can then
design our medium and our feeding
strategy what i'm going to show you next
is
the medium what you see here on the top
left
is the medium composition
so the uh different
amino acids for
three different medium in blue is
our medium the energy based medium
in red or pink
is the amino acid composition
of gibco's city hybrid dome
medium we had to reverse engineer that
gift would not
tell us the amino acid composition and
in yellow you have
a medium composition by
from a paper by a swedish group
that predicted or
experimentally said what would be the
optimal um
amino acid composition um all three
media are specific
for the ns0 cell line so there are a
couple of things to point out
here the first one is that uh in the
graph next to uh the medium composition
whereby the r model dynamically
shows the variation in amino acid
composition
what our model says is that
the amino acid compositions
that are really required utilized by the
cell
is between zero and four millimolar
and if you look at the uh bottom left
graph
what you will see is that the
commercially available gibco cd
hybridoma
culture medium has amino acid
compositions that are
10 10 times one fold higher so instead
of
zero to four which is what the cells
need
uh gibco's medium provides
amino acid compositions that are you
know
up to 40 millimolars that
means amino acid accumulation
unnecessary
unnecessary cost but also providing
amino acids that
may affect and will affect the
metabolism of the cells
the second thing i want to point out is
this
medium that was experimentally designed
by the swedish group
which was in the same range as our
model based design
medium but what the swedish group could
not do
as shown in the bottom right figure
is when these amino acids would be
exhausted
so in inadvertently they had a
limitation of essential amino acids
and as a result in their paper they
achieved lower growth
longevity and production
so what is the limit of our work well
our energy-based medium
when we looked at it in a fed batch
culture
and we compare it with a traditional
fedbat culture
using the gibco medium
what we achieved was extending cultural
longevity by at least 24 hours
achieving higher cell density and
increasing significantly
productivity in a vast culture by
a hundred percent in a fed bath culture
by
close to 200 percent
so
this is the first part in terms of
medium design
the last part and the last few slides
have to do with feeding sweat
the traditional feeding strategy right
now is by and large empirical
companies have immense expertise it
requires one sensor per control
nutrient uh it's a complicated process
what we are suggesting and what i'm
going to show you in unpublished data
that our model predicts the nutrient
consumption
our feeding strategy does not require
extra sensors and what
we can achieve is
uh we can achieve a fitting strategy
using only two set points enabling us
enabling us to control again all the
carbon sources
and all 20 amino acids
um and um achieving as i'll show you
right now superior in the next
slide superior
[Music]
productivity performance what our
fitting strategy says
in the top graphs for both glucose
and amino acid feeding is that it should
be an automatic continuous fitting
versus a pulse feeding
so our objective function was to
minimize
error between nutrients all right
that's to minimize our predictions with
uh
with the experimental data and the
target value
and we've set uh upper
nutrient and lower nutrient constraints
for viability purposes what
we can achieve is avoid as i'll show you
accumulation of amino acids and
exhaustion of amino acids
so what you see here in this graph for
glutamine
arginine proline aspartate and
asparagine
is that by our strategy which is shown
in the solid line and the
points are the experimental data and
the traditional feeding strategy we
avoid
exhaustion let's look at glutamate
between
50 and 100 hours whereby
you would have traditionally exhaustion
of glutamate
we avoid this exhaustion of glutamate we
avoid
uh providing too much glutamate once you
start feeding again
we avoid the metabolic shift and we can
keep
lower concentrations of glutamate the
same is true for arginine proline and so
forth
so we avoid nutrient exhaustion
but also we avoid uh nutrient
amino acid accumulation in particular
these examples so
setting and glycine
so we have again a fitting strategy that
is tailor-made
uh it achieves better performance it
significantly reduces uh operational
costs
it is much much easier in terms of both
hardware
and operation and
[Music]
we're not even done in terms of the
optimization
so my last slide and to summarize
everything
is the future direction so our future
direction
is a company that we have set up which
we call
sanika for precision biomanufacturing
whereby again we can
utilizing customer data
in terms of cell product composition
growth kinetics tailoring made tailoring
the metabolic uh profile for the
uh um specific cells
in a cell type cell line clone and
product specific manner
uh and coming up with uh
an optimal medium a design and an
optimal
feeding strategy and with that i would
like to uh
end and thank you for your attention